[Musik]
hallo ihr Lieben wir machen heute
Fingerfood jedes Jahr meiner Ramadan
Reihe gibt es immer ein besonderes
Fingerfood wir hatten schon panierte
Zigarette Börek richtig lecker liebe ich
wir hatten crispyric mit Pankow
Paniermehl auch richtig geil und dieses
Jahr mache ich das sehr schnelles und
sehr einfaches was ich für zwischendurch
eigentlich immer sehr mag auch außerhalb
des Ramadan natürlich ähm wie z.B für
grillveranstaltungen oder einfach als
Party food wir machen so Blätterteig
Spinat feta-taschen und das ist ein
super schnelles Rezept deshalb schnibbel
ich ja auch schon Zwiebel fein und hat
dann gleich auch noch Knoblauch und dann
zeige ich euch jetzt Schritt für Schritt
wie es geht und die genauen
Mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wie
immer hier unten in der Infobox dann
könnt ihr einfach einen Screenshot
machen und einkaufen gehen
[Musik]
so jetzt mache ich mich hier an meine
Pfanne gib etwas Olivenöl rein und
dünste dann zwiebeln und Knoblauch an so
zwei Minütchen und dann gebe ich Spinat
dazu ihr könnt auch TK-Spinat nehmen das
funktioniert auch wunderbar
so und der Spinat wird dann einfach nur
noch blanchiert also eine Minute
vielleicht der wird ja dann so richtig
einsinken und dann würzen wir das Ganze
[Musik]
so wenn ihr sogar kurz den Deckel drauf
macht geht es noch schneller falls der
Spinat wässrig sein sollte dann einfach
mit einem Zewa entfernen also rausnehmen
jetzt am liebsten nicht auf hoher Hitze
köcheln lassen und gehen ja auch die
ganzen Nährstoffe kaputt ich habe den
Herd ausgeschaltet gebe jetzt noch
Fetakäse mit dazu dann gebe ich einfach
in so großen Brocken rein und werde ihn
dann mit der Gabel einfach zerdrücken
und ich kann auch schon mal würzen dann
haben wir nämlich alles drin und zwar
natürlich mit
Fetakäse ist ja auch schon ein bisschen
salzig daher immer schön vorsichtig
Pfeffer und was ich mega geil finde aber
super untypisch auch für spinat ist
Curry einfach eine Curry Gewürzmischung
mit dazugeben und dann ist die Füllung
fertig
[Musik]
jetzt geht es ans befüllen ich nehme
immer ganz gerne tiefkühlblätterteig das
ist dieser hier der kommt immer in so
Rechtecken ihr könnt aber auch den ganz
normalen aus dem Kühlregal nehmen das
funktioniert genauso gut beim
tiefkühlblätterteig ist es so dass wenn
ihr jetzt Dreiecke macht also ihr
halbiert erstmal den Blätterteig bzw
könnt vorher noch mal ein bisschen
flache ausrollen weil dann ist es
einfacher dass ihr perfekte Dreiecke
habt eigentlich müsste nur der Länge
nach ein bisschen Rollen weil diese
blätterteige sind halten ein bisschen
kurz was aber gar nicht schlimm ist ich
mache jetzt hier einmal ein Schnitt mit
habt ihr halt perfekte Quadrate wenn ihr
jetzt so schneiden würde in der Mitte
dann sind keine Quadrate sondern
Rechtecke also es hört sich jetzt
kompliziert an aber wenn ihr es macht
dann werdet ihr diesen aha Moment haben
denn jetzt gebe ich hier die Füllung in
die eine Ecke
und dann klappen wir das einfach um und
jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Kleber
also irgendwas dass das zusammenhält ihr
könnt entweder jetzt auch mit der Gabel
das ganze hier andrücken oder was sie
auch zusätzlich machen könnte damit es
schön zu bleibt ist eine
Milchmischung die wir sowieso später
brauchen um die Blätterteig Teilchen
damit zu bestreichen damit sie natürlich
auch schön goldbraun sind ich finde das
gehört immer mit dazu dann sind sie so
blass und dann sehen sie einfach nicht
lecker aus
[Musik]
habe ich euch was zu Backzeit gesagt ja
was denn also im vorgeheizten Ofen könnt
ihr ein Blech backen bei 190 Grad Ober
und Unterhitze das braucht dann 24
Minuten ihr könnt aber auch zwei welche
gleichzeitig reinschieben dann bitte
auch Umluft stellen allerdings 170 Grad
in Umluft ist immer ein bisschen heißer
und dann ebenfalls 24 Minuten da tut
sich nichts an der Zeit
was hast du denn schönes gezaubert mir
ich habe unser diesjähriges Fingerfood
für Ramadan gemacht fehlt hast
immer so erstmal weil diese crispy
erstmal aber letztes Jahr glaube
super Idee
[Musik]
lecker ich liebe das Suppe ja das habe
ich extra gemacht für so als
suppenbeilage
machen aber
die Füllung ist mega mega Salz Pfeffer
Curry ich sag's euch curry ist das Ding
ist ultra lecker
mit grünen Spinat auch kommen
mega Leute macht es nach wir haben gut
vorbereitet dieses Jahr muss ich sagen
und ich werde während Ramadan viele
tiktoks und wheels und Youtube Shorts
sehen immer wieder eure Wünsche hier
rein ich habe während Ramadan so viel
Zeit weil alles mögliche vor gedreht
haben für die Youtube stolz auf mich
also ich würde mal sagen
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten Mal
ciao
[Musik]